let's start it off tonight with a street
fighter character I have never used them
at all except of course in street fun
start off with Ryu here let's go with
like that white it's pretty cool I'm
curious to see how a fighting game
character translates to a game like
Smash Brothers I really am because if
they made them like they really are in
their fighting game it wouldn't work
hold on let me pause this I have
something in my eye here before we get
started and of course it's gonna start
us off against his fellow Street Fighter
character Ken
all right so I'm just trying to get a
feel for the moves here oh this is a man
you got a love that they it is a stamina
battle too
it's not a traditional holy block that
okay I'm let's see this is as neutral
they attack right here here's this beat
oh so you don't okay you just hit B and
he'll do the Hadouken now if you do the
traditional Street Fighter input for the
Hadouken you get a special version so
when I do when it's blue that's just a
normal one oh man did I run out or
something
all right let's see here forward beat is
a spin kick
alright see if I can get it huh there we
go that one right there
so the blue one is when you have just a
regular you just press B and it does it
you don't have to input the commands
like you do if you're actually playing
Street Fighter here you can just tap B
and then to do the the red one that you
saw that is when you actually put in the
down diagonal forward
yikes are they all gonna be stamina
battles that is pretty cool man if so
that's pretty cool make it feel more
like a street fighter game whoa whoa
you know he's got to get the uppercut in
there
[Music]
sure you can
okay that's his up smash right there
forward smash is the kick man after
playing the stamina modes that you run
into for the world of light this might
be this might be a lot easier in classic
mode man some of the stamina ones you
run into during world of light or took
off dude
oh oh okay so his upbeat is the
shoryuken and smash attack is an
uppercut as well but all right this
guy's ahead of me right now I got to
step up my game step up my game on in
center or here Oh close right now you
guys are subscriber on YouTube I
actually updated added a new video today
oh crap oh crap come on bro don't just
hide over there in the corner
yeah uploaded a video today of my in
center or classic mode play through so
I'm trying to go through and you'll see
this one on youtube eventually as well
hi youtube of every single character in
the game I'm sure it's already been done
somewhere but I just think it's a fun
little challenge to try and undertake
especially since Smash Brothers ultimate
we have so many characters more than
ever before I think it's like 74 76 I
don't even know the final total but I
know it's in the 70s which is crazy well
you got a spin kick too DK actually I
guess he uses his arms for that one
[Music]
what is this little I can't figure out
how I okay that's just down be right
there I'm not really sure what that it's
a very slow move so I don't know if it's
some kind of stun or maybe like a parry
it's just very slow the left experiment
around with that one see if we can
figure that out so so far all of these
furry you have been stamina fights which
if you're not super familiar with Smash
Brothers it doesn't work like a
traditional fighting game where you you
have your stamina meter and then you
just deplete the other person instead
you actually build up normally you build
up ones percent at the bottom and then
the higher their percent the easier it
is to knock them off or smash break it's
the name Smash Brothers smash them off
the stage well Rio of course comes from
Street Fighter a very traditional
fighting game and it looks like to sort
of honor the fighting game he comes from
oh no come on
there we go to honor where Ryu comes
from they have included all stamina
fights at least so far they've all been
stamina fights here for his playthrough
oh you like that using the spin kick to
slip in there at the last second I mean
there's got to be a way to get up there
and get those I'm determined not to
watch a video because I want to figure
that out I want to figure out how you
get up there on that part
I really do I want to know all right
that's a little interesting that the the
puzzle is done early for Reeves see
we've still got two fights plus the
final boss normally that special bonus
stage comes right before the final guy
[Music]
whoa whoa slow down little man slow down
buddy
he's playing like very passive but he
see us so far oh oh I shouldn't said
anything guys I honestly should not have
said anything
got to keep my distance now man when
little Matt gets in close on you he can
rack up the damage oh no oh no oh no
you've been doing so well I think I just
need to stop playing passive oh it's one
way to do it right there just jump off
moon princess hello there thanks for
stopping by playing on the GameCube
controller I'm actually not I'm using
the switch Pro as much as I love the
GameCube controller and man I love the
GameCube controller it's been my
favorite controller for a long time but
something about this smash brother just
felt like maybe the right time to try
try something different in so far I'm
I'm not having any issues with the
switch pro controller I may get the
adapter eventually because I have so
many GameCube controllers lying around
so it'd be good for parties when you
have people over you just pull it out
and then lots of people can play cuz I
only have four switch I only have the
pro controller and then the joy cons
that it comes with so but yeah so far
I'm enjoying the pro controller I
actually think the pro controller is
really really comfortable and probably
rivals the Gamecube like in terms of its
build quality well we made it pretty far
without having to use a little continue
there I still think it's interesting how
they've changed up classic mode because
you used to be able to have a stock so
you didn't really technically have to
quit when you died once as you had a
stock to go through
it's kind of an interesting tweak on it
though this system the way it works now
man he just hopped right over that I can
definitely feel it getting harder as
I've went along here what's supposed to
do mean yikes dude why is that that
shouldn't come on man that should go
through his attack
oh good
and what a Dodge what a Dodge I feel
like they made the computer smarter in
this one I feel like they're a lot
smarter like the fact that he dodged
that right there come on
so yeah it's it looks like they're
continuing with the theme through the
whole Ryu classic mode of it being all
stamina favorite characters this time
around that's a good question I still
don't have them all unlocked yet so I
mean Samus has always been my go-to so I
still like Samus a lot but the other
ones that I really want to jump down and
and really like spend a lot more time
with oh this is pretty cool
Ryu and Ken obviously stamina battle
again since its Master Hand and crazy oh
man we've gotten this guy down quick
come on Ken fight him hit him and we
might be able to take master Kent down
pretty soon I'm working on crazy in here
see if I can get him stunned should be
pretty close to being stunned
yeah there he goes now let's work on get
master hand off the stage dodge this
[Music]
see like that right there man he just
honed in exactly where I was that's
gonna knock me off isn't it oh thank
goodness
crazy hands almost down to get away from
that get away from that yeah go after
him okay that's fine good good good game
over I am super excited about Joker I
could not believe that I could not
believe Moon Princess in the chat asked
about Joker those of you don't know the
persona 5 protagonist the main character
of persona those hands are are
definitely creepy one of the strangest
like bosses of any game probably yet
they keep coming back
they've always masked your hand it's
just been a staple of the series for a
long long time yeah I want to I want to
ant fully answer that question though
about the other characters here once I
pull up my character screen I feel like
the big newcomer that a lot of people
are in playing and the online matches
I've watched is the inkling splatoon of
course one of the newer Nintendo
franchises that oh I believe that's
Ganondorf get an Dorf yes indeed
oh now I gotta remember it's not a
stamina fight
what like something pulled me to him is
that new I don't know if the wind was
balling or if he actually I know that's
not how that move has always behaved
dude he's he's destroying me yeah come
on where's the rider man I keep doing
that move when I'm trying to actually do
the hadouken hadouken all right all
right we're making it close now yeah
there it is
I mean pushing B does the blue one the
red one
alright yeah I think I'm getting it
hey that's heyo power - we've already
seen it oh gosh watch out me and I had
to play that one super safe to unlock
him there super safe but welcome
Ganondorf thank you so much for joining
the battle
it's